foreign
it's kind of personal for you too
welcome to the welcome to the club
though I should say I got initiated into
the club it's funny the very first time
I was on here with Dave we know we did a
little social media post and a guy came
in there and he was like so because you
know I told a little of my story and the
guy says so basically all you have to do
is be an idiot with money and Dave
Ramsey will hire you yeah and I'm
thinking yeah I did dumb stuff with
money yeah and then a couple days later
lady comes on and says who would ever
listen to you
and I'm like okay okay okay okay because
you paid off almost 500 Grand in debt
and changed your life okay that's that's
why people would listen to you because
you know what it's like to dig a deep
hole and then get out yeah man I told so
that's who I want to hear from by the
way I don't want to hear from somebody
who don't have any scars oh man when Sam
and I were getting out of debt so for
those of you who don't know my husband
and I we got married uh and soon after
you know your student loans don't become
due until about six months after you
actually graduate so we didn't really
realize what we had combined so about
six eight months into marriage we
realized we were deeply deeply deeply
into debt most of it was student loan
debt uh 280 000 of it with student loans
and the rest two cars that we couldn't
afford 20 000 in credit cards in the end
we had 460 000 wow in debt and when we
started when we started I got a little
bit of an attitude because I know folks
some folks have made me a little bit
salty kin so I have a little bit of
attitude in my voice when we started our
income was 30k because we were musicians
fresh out I worked at a clothing store
and you know we had Big Dreams and it
was like okay what are we gonna do put
up or you know buck up or get out of
here you know something so we started
working and um we were working for a
Cruise Line Traveling all around the
world uh we ended up starting a business
to try to get our income up and it
worked and we did any and everything we
could in between our normal music jobs
to earn money can you have a place to
live or were you just live in on a
cruise ship we were okay so you go out
there for just a couple of days at a
time and then you fly home it's a lot of
flights and we were living in a
townhouse and we got roommates
yeah married folks with roommates with
roommates because you were hardly ever
there uh we were there enough we were
there enough so so you're like you were
like the real life Friends episode ah it
was it you know they were always there
yeah I'll be there at the yeah they were
there all the time and uh we did that to
save 600 bucks a month and we did all
sorts of things Ken yeah we didn't have
a we sold all of our furniture
slept on an air mattress that's all you
had we slept on an air mattress for five
years Ken Coleman so when when people
come at me and and they don't they don't
think I'm qualified to teach this a man
with an experience is never at the mercy
of a man with an opinion because I did
this Sam warshaw Jade warshaw we did
this you guys have long-term
Chiropractic Care not dude you were okay
when you're in your 20s you're made out
of rubber man you can do all you had in
the uh townhome was an air mattress we
had an air mattress for a good minute
and I remember when we saved up enough
cash and we bought these Pho like you
know the faux leather oh yeah that when
you can't afford the the Italian leather
oh yeah we had these you stick to it
yeah you're like when you get up to go
to the bathroom when you're watching a
game you know what I mean and the leg
goes like this yeah right off the top
but we were so excited to have them we
slept on them like we were like I'm
sleeping with us yeah of course but I'm
saying you know the the sacrifice to win
to walk through the baby steps yeah and
to walk through baby step two it took us
seven and a half years to do that Ken
and that's why she's actually here
because she did it I don't want to take
advice from a professor I don't want to
take a business class from a professor
that has never run a successful business
so why would you take Financial advice
from somebody who's never failed
financially yeah and then had to win
yeah and and that's the thing all you
haters out there don't get me started on
the kids
hater raid I mean they're they're
cowards because they like to fire stuff
from the safety of the keyboard they'd
never say it to your face no and so I
don't listen to cowards in fact the uh
the team over on the Ken Coleman show
they're instructed
all negative comments
I don't mean like healthy constructive
well yeah because we do want to learn
from yeah yeah but I mean just the nasty
like you're an idiot whatever well sure
I wouldn't argue with you for two
seconds about it and that's the thing
but I'm not gonna read that crap so it
goes immediately into the deleted folder
so if you think you're really getting at
us you're not yeah take your Venom
somewhere else because we're you're
really trying to help you yeah we hear
you guys you guys are you what you're
going through we care about that and
have walked through it and have walked
through it so the things that we're
telling you is things that we have done
things that we have tried things that we
have felt we're right there with you man
if you're in baby step two and if you're
in what I call the six figure Freedom
Club where you're trying to pay off six
figures or more of debt I see you man I
I feel you I feel your pain I feel the
struggle when you when it's Friday night
like tonight
and everybody else is going out what'd
you do on Friday night take me back
since we got the air mattress what was
Friday night when you guys were broke
nacho night
make some nachos at the crib
like hold on because you're a good cook
what was old school broke Jade nachos
was it the the shredded cheese melted or
was it real nacho cheese no no it was
honestly it was whatever we had whatever
we had in the in the refrigerator that's
what I was gonna figure out something to
make I did not so some nights it was
like vegan nachos sunlight it was
protein nachos no no it was we we keep
it clean it's always vegan don't get it
twisted Ken well don't be trying to get
it twisted I'm actually asking because
you're a clean folks don't know you're a
super cleaner so how do you eat clean
when you're broke because I'd be getting
the government cheese for my nachos on
the outside you got to stay on the
outside of the grocery store because
that's where all the healthy stuff is
fruits vegetables all the produce and
then if you're gonna go on the inner
aisles that's where you get your
proteins so your nuts your beans that
kind of thing right and you buy what's
on sale and what you can't buy fresh you
buy Frozen and what you can't afford to
buy Frozen you buy in a can that's how
you do it if you can't afford to buy the
fresh spinach you buy the frozen spinach
page right and you just work on down if
you can't get the the fresh carrots you
buy the Frozen carrots if you can't get
the Frozen carrots then you get the
canned carrots and you just go on down
the line like that that's good but don't
nobody no one can tell me that oh
there's no way to eat healthy when you
don't have money you do not have to buy
ramen noodles you do not have to buy
McDonald's because McDonald's is not
cheap anymore by the way you go through
uh fast food with kids yeah you're
spending seventy dollars